Hey David, are race based dating preferences
and sexual preferences, a form of racism.
So I'm going to answer this as asked because
there is, you know, sort of the most narrow
answer to a question like this. But it's important
to understand, and I mentioned this before,
very often these types of questions are not
asked in good faith. And I'm not saying Ken
is not asking the question in good faith,
it's just important to understand how very
often there are people who ask these questions
in order to elicit a particular answer, which
then is used to justify some further bad argument
or bad take. And I don't want to be doing
that. So I'll sort of get to that in a little
bit. So in the most technical sense is something
like I'm a white male. I am not attracted
to Asian women or black women. Is that racism?
If you want to play the linguistic game, strictly
speaking, that is something called sexual
racism.
Now don't be triggered by the word. Okay,
we're trying to have adult conversation here.
Conversations here. We're trying to have conversations
that have context, so don't just go crazy
because I'm calling something racism. This
is actually a deep topic with a lot of nuance
behind it and there's really a lot of sociology
and a lot of things behind this. On the one
hand, people are attracted to certain other
people, oftentimes for reasons that are not
particularly discernible. Sometimes people
have a preference for thinner or heavier,
uh, of others. Sometimes for certain hair
colors, sometimes complexion, certain personalities,
uh, assert certain hobbies or religion or
skin color, right? Race is a completely reasonable
basis where one might have a sort of base
level predisposition in favor of or against.
When it comes to physical attraction. And
in principle, this is no big deal. This is
not evidence of systemic, uh, cultural racism.
This, it's none of those things. Okay. Now
let's go beyond that. There is also a reality
that sometimes those preferences can be culturally
ingrained through discriminatory or racist
messages that are sometimes reinforced, uh,
by society and culture. So for example, some
countries have cast systems and those cast
systems can pervade so strongly that people
believe that something is merely a casual
preference about physical appearance, for
example. But it's actually ingrained multi-generationally
by teaching that people of a certain cast
are dirty or toxic or to be avoided or whatever.
And it's important to understand that you
might think, I just happen not to be attracted
to X, and X could be a racial characteristic,
or it could be a physical characteristic of
some other kind or whatever the case may be.
And you may not even have an awareness that
it is something cultural that has been ingrained
that is actually responsible for that.
Does that mean that it should be enforced
that even if you don't find certain races
attractive, you should have to date them?
Of course not. Of course not. We're not talking
about that. We're just trying to have a more
nuanced and deep understanding of where some
of these preferences can come from in the
United States to, you know, the cast example
is not super relevant in the U S in the U
S attitudes towards interracial relationships
do affect attitudes about other races sexually,
which can translate to someone thinking, I
just happen not to be attracted to someone
from a certain race, but it be connected to
historical discrimination and taboos about
interracial marriage, which fortunately are
less prevalent in 2019 than they were 50 years
ago. But still to some degree exist. I know
people who tend to date only outside their
race. I know both men and women that are heterosexual
and I know gay men, all of whom have dating
preferences that are for those who are not
part of their racial group.
Uh, it could be by chance, it could be connected
to something in their upbringing. Who knows?
So that's the analysis. In a literal sense,
sexual racism is a thing. And I apologize
for hitting my microphone there. Uh, is this
the type of systemic racism that is endemic
of, uh, is is, uh, a prototypical of the problems
in society? No, it's not. And I'm not saying
that and that's where I think the broader
analysis comes in. The reality is that making
questions of racism about something like sexual
preferences is very often a distraction sometimes
used in bad faith by people who either want
to create fake drama around dating preferences
or uh, to use acceptance for dating preferences
on the basis of race to justify further segregation.
There is a case that some on the internet
like to make that listen, if it's okay to
only want to date people of certain races,
then what's the big deal with more segregation?
Like why don't we live around people of our
own race. And the next thing you know, you're
talking about something like what Richard
Spencer has proposed, a peaceful segregation,
uh, on the races of base. So it's important.
I'm glad to address these questions as if
they are good faith questions and I believe
with peace and love that Ken was asking it
in good faith, but I would be doing you a
disservice if I didn't tell you that these
types of questions are often used by bad faith
actors to either trick or induce fruitless
or false debates that are really a distraction
from the issues that as a society we're trying
to solve. If you disagree with me, let me
know. I can't wait to hear from you.